the Emmy award-winning series done no no
that's how madmen used to go showed us
the pressures of the New York
advertising world in the 1960s
advertising is based on one thing
happiness and you know what happiness is
happiness is the smell of a new car it's
freedom from fear it's a billboard on
the side of the road that screams with
reassurance that whatever you're doing
it's okay
but the best-selling author and longtime
New Yorker calmness that's Ken Auletta
says the industry is no longer operating
in the style of Don Draper his new book
is called frenemies the epic disruption
of the ad business and everything else
it explores a shift in global
advertising and what it means for the
future of media Ken Auletta has reported
on the digital revolution over the past
three decades and he joins us we're
happy to say at the table hello Ken a
lot of morning I love the title of your
book frenemies because I know normally
it means we're friends but I really
don't like you so how does that apply in
the advertising business well if you're
an agency suddenly the people who are
your friends yeah Google and Facebook
are competing and going directly to
clients your clients are increasingly
saying I want to take stuff in-house and
miss the agency and and the publishers
the New York Times BuzzFeed etcetera who
you put your ads on they're suddenly
saying hey we can be ad agencies to
going directly to the clients but the
biggest frenemy is in fact the public
the public on their particular on their
mobile devices don't want to be
interrupted by terrible ads yeah and
30-second spots don't work small screens
don't allow big big video ads and people
are saying why are you doing this to me
and then they say the advertiser thing
comes back and says well we're gonna
give you ads as information because
we'll know so much about you isn't this
great
and then the public begins to say they
were in a second how do you know someone
so much because more people you say are
on their phones and watching TV and the
phone is a very personal device is why
carry a wallet yeah so how much of a
crisis is this both within the
advertising industry but also to the
things that exist because of advertising
well that's one of the
if you follow the money as I tried to do
here advertising and marketing is up to
two trillion dollar worldwide industry
it supports all media 97% of Facebook's
revenues come from from advertising yeah
almost 90% of Google is come from that
newspapers magazines much of television
apps all dependent on on advertising so
if that money dries up the consequences
are profound
well it and describe how that relates to
sort of what was considered the
traditional media networks like CBS and
others and newspapers those that usually
got most of not all of their money from
average when I did a book on the
network's in 1991 three blow my mind a
hundred percent of the revenues of say
CBS came from advertising today 46% does
CBS and les moonves who's the head of
CBS is one of the characters in the book
they have done a very good job of
relying on other revenue sources which
is one of the challenges for every
newspapers have that problem how do I
get other revenue sources CBS and the
other networks have had that they sell
to digital companies like Netflix and
Amazon they get retransmission consent
from the cable companies in return for
their programs and they own they now are
allowed to own programs and sell them so
they have other source of revenue and
that's good but if that 46% of
advertising goes down to 25% CBS intro
how do you get out well yeah go ahead
well subscriptions some people have
tried to get subscriptions from going
right to the user get them to pay more
is that going to make up for that well I
mean we could the four of us could
afford to pay more in subscriptions but
the average American spends roughly $250
a month and that doesn't cover their
prescriptions for for Con Ed or power
and stuff like that the one thing that
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton agreed
on the campaign is that the working
class and the in the middle class their
income was frozen for the last ten years
how do they afford more subscription
yeah it's it's a wonderful idea but it's
a pipe dream the game is definitely
changed you talk about the characters in
the book which I think are really great
you've got les Moonves to be described
as as Steve Jobs of TV brilliant
operator who likes to win Carolyn D
versa news a badass at Facebook and then
Michael Carson talk start with Carolyn
ever said about why she house
factors into this game and Michael cos
well here she is they tell the story in
the book I thank you very well the book
in a way and I have a chapter on this
it's gone from Mad Men
yes amassment math men of the engineers
and the data scientists so here's
Carolyn Davidson who comes out of the
advertising world she's very good she's
a great salesperson she's a great people
person Facebook but she she works for
for a company that's based on
engineering and so she's trying to put a
friendly face on on what many people in
the advertising community see is an
unfriendly company Michael Catherine
Michael Carson is a connector to a very
insecure industry people who are full of
anxieties that everybody's scared
basically they are scared I mean it's it
but disruption scares a lot of people if
you go to the newspaper industry and do
interviews or even much of the
television stream people are scared
people what terrified of Netflix yeah
and so insecurity means that if you can
find a character like Michael Casson
what I call the connector he basically
he represents everybody represents
clients he represents publishers
represents Facebook and Google yeah okay
can I let a good reader from yes it is
indeed
thanks very much frenemies goes on sale
Tuesday